hi ollie nice to talk to you great to
see you yeah well i you know it's so
funny this strange world you're
connected with people that you've never
met you see
their faces you know their
thumbnails as you know their personality
and facebook and whatever so it's nice
to talk
yeah likewise i mean i've been watching
your your videos for many years it's
great to finally get the chance to to
talk
and you know i i must admit before i got
involved in all of this uh online
polyglottery
uh i didn't even know well i shouldn't
say i didn't know but the word polyglot
was like a strange word to me and i
think a majority of english speakers
still don't know what the word polyglot
means
and there was a great controversy over
it the word to me has always been
linguist someone who likes languages who
speaks languages as a linguist anyway we
won't get into that discussion but a lot
of people always ask polyglots like you
and me
how do you learn more than one language
how do you maintain more than one
language isn't there interference from
one language to another how do you deal
with juggling all these languages so
maybe you could start just commenting on
that subject
yeah absolutely well i mean i i'm also
someone that kind of dislikes these
labels of polyglot and linguist i think
it's unhelpful a lot of the time
it's unhelpful to the general
conversation
of uh of
you know what we want to do it just to
encourage people to learn languages
for me um so you know i am someone with
no language background from childhood so
when i was um
when i was 18 19 i hadn't learned any
other languages
and so it's been a very very gradual
evolution for me and it in every case
what's led my language learning has been
people and relationships
um so you know whether it's a case of um
you know i moved to spend a bit of time
in paris when i was about 19
i learned french
moved to london my best friend was from
canary island so i learned spanish fell
in with a brazilian crowd and learned
portuguese
um decided to go and teach english in
japan so i learned japanese and it's a
very
a very natural evolution like that and i
think
one of the interesting things for me is
that i like i have
only recently in the last couple of
years discovered the kind of online
world of polyglots another kind of the
uh the mystique of you like that
surrounds that and it's been odd for me
because
i i've kind of had to reverse engineer
my thoughts about language learning it's
been such a natural process for me
that um when i first started doing
things online i didn't really know how
to articulate
my experiences and my learning process
because it was that kind of natural
thing so um
it's been something it's an ongoing
process for me and um
so you asked about maintaining languages
well first of all interference now
you've got uh three uh at least three
possibly more romance languages do you
find that the that one interferes with
the other
well i have found that in the past but i
don't currently find it um and i explain
why um
the time that it was worst for me was
actually after i spent some time
learning italian and i got to a fairly
decent conversational level in italian
but never kept it up
and so when i
took up spanish after that i kind of
gave spanish my all um had a great group
of friends in london who were who were
spanish and spoke that language a lot
whilst i was here and never kept up my
italian and so
kind of going back and forth between
that was um i very quickly lost my
ability in italian because i simply
didn't give up
after that when i learned portuguese
again i went through an intensive period
i always tend to go through intensive
periods of learning one language at a
time
and i think that's
that you know that seems to me to be the
the most effective way of acquiring
ability in a language
but then of course the question is a bit
interference well how does that affect
the language you've done before and
i remember when i came back from brazil
the first time i
i sat down with a spanish friend of mine
in in in london and he was speaking a
little bit of spanish
and she just turned around to me and
said um
like what's going on with your with your
spanish i was speaking spanish with
portuguese brazilian portuguese grammar
which is quite different
and
there was significant interference there
because i spent so much time just
immersed in portuguese
luckily what i was able to do was
because i have a music background i went
out and played a lot of brazilian music
in london at the time i was able to
spend a lot of time surrounded by
uh both south american spanish speakers
and brazilians and so for a period of
time i would often speak spanish and
portuguese a lot in in one evening
and i often equate that experience to
actually learning a new language because
i had to learn to kind of manipulate
both together
and i was able to get rid of that
interference and separate them in my
mind and now i can speak both of them
without much interference but it was a
process of learning to do that and it
was far from automatic right no i i you
know i'm glad to hear that you have that
problem because i just this this morning
before we got started here i had a 45
minute conversation in russian
and i speak russian a lot better than
ukrainian but i've been focusing on
ukrainian this past month and then i was
at a conference in toronto where i was
speaking ukrainian all day long i really
struggled i kept ukrainian kept on
creeping into my russian but um
i i think it's partly a matter of how
well we know the language so that i will
not confuse french and spanish not a
chance sure once i get into portuguese i
could confuse that with spanish italian
in other words the better you know the
language the less likely you are
to allow other languages to interfere
with it and this gets back to the
subject of of maintaining the languages
too i find that
um
you know if you ask me okay like my top
five languages i don't have to worry if
i'm going to have to have a conversation
a meeting and whatever in japanese or
china it's not a problem i don't have to
don't have to do anything
if on the other hand my next five group
i might want to spend a day or two yeah
and i tend to
i tend to work with reading and
listening to me that's enough i can't
necessarily go out and grab some german
speakers and and and or whatever and you
know italian speakers here or russian
speakers so and really before speaking
to my russian tutor i should have spent
a couple of hours on link just reading
and listening to russian so but then the
weakest five
which includes ukrainian and czech and
korean
there it like i'd almost have to work
like a few weeks to get it up to a level
where it won't be vulnerable to
interference from other languages so i i
think the big issue there is a in terms
of maintaining your language and b in
terms of
protecting it from interference from
others is just how well you know it and
the better you know it the less you have
to prepare
well i think there's no doubt that i
mean i i've certainly found that with
the languages where i've reached a very
very very
a very
strong conversational level where i've
kind of you know i can operate in the
language
um day in day out with no particular
problems i've never experienced that
dropping
to
beneath that point right get a bit rusty
but nothing that can't be reactivated
within 15 minutes i've never had that
experience um but like earlier on i
mentioned my italian which never really
got that high i mean that was striking
for me how just how easy that was
actually lost right um i i wonder if
there's i mean i've heard people mention
before
there's you know potentially
neuroplasticity things that have come to
bear with this you know when you when
you speak a language over time i think
your brain
and i have no scientific basis for
saying this but it's just my my
intuition that your brain
does adapt to that way of thinking in
the language because every language has
a different
approach to
explaining ideas and conveying thoughts
and i've i wonder if um it's not the
case that when your brain gets so used
to doing that in one language
it doesn't then
kind of demold if you like it kind of
it's there and it's fixed and you can
access that again but if you only get up
to a an intermediate level or so um that
it isn't quite fixed enough for that to
remain permanent i mean that's that's my
impression it's probably
i tell you what i think though i think
that if you go back to your italian or
whenever maybe that already happened
that when you went back to your italian
and you were rusty rusty and you felt
you lost a lot it wouldn't take very
long before you felt stronger in italian
than you ever had been
in other words that's that's definitely
possible and my experience has been that
first of all i often talk about this
interleaving the fact that you go away
from italian do some spanish and then
come back to italian and then you you
re-connect some of the neural neurons
that were were connected became
unconnected they become stronger than
they ever were and there's actually uh
you know neurological evidence that this
forgetting and relearning forgetting and
relearning actually strengthens your
hold
uh so and the other thing too is is
learning similar languages where you're
most likely to get interference actually
helps you like with every slavic
language that i learn i create more
confusion but at the same time i am
confirming some of the basic common
patterns you know structural patterns of
the language and the same is true with
even though portuguese has some
differences with spanish 80 90 of the
grammar is the same
and and the vocabulary is essentially
the same so you're actually confirming
your knowledge of that other language
but you're introducing some interference
if you then go back to the portuguese or
the italian and work at it for a little
while in my view you become stronger the
other thing i want to say i don't see it
so much as different languages have
different and say call it cultural ways
of approaching things i the way i see it
is
you've got these different control
centers in your brain
so a person who only speaks one language
has got one control center call it
english or chinese or whatever it might
be and at that point they're not very
flexible so that the new
language with the new patterns
it takes a bit of a
more effort than to create this new
control center and then you create a
third one and a fourth one the brain
becomes more and more flexible but but
by being more flexible there's also more
opportunity that you're looking for when
it goes down the wrong path and you end
up in
the lane in another language not the one
you want
right
so so then you need to kind of work on
that language for a while to kind of
reestablish the strength of those
connections for that control center
that's all and i get i guess the
strongest evidence for that is when you
if you know if one comes to learn their
fourth or fifth romance language say
right in your case maybe the slavic
language i mean it's significantly
easier oh yes i mean portuguese for me
my fourth romance language was right i
mean it it didn't it really didn't take
that long no and that's
that's i'm sure that is because of um
the
the fact that i noticed the connections
between
the uh the other romance languages i've
learned and the way you manipulate verbs
and nouns and things like that and it
just because
the logic is there and it stays it stays
like that i haven't had so much
experience in
language groups a different language
group so i i i would uh be interested to
hear whether you've had a similar
experience in slavic well yeah i mean
i've done basically i've got my romance
you know five romance four slavic uh
call it four asian
and then german swedish english call
them germanic or whatever english is i'm
not so sure
uh
the the thing is like swedish is kind of
off on its own so i don't get confused
the romance languages i don't really get
confused but the slavic languages are
relatively new for me so i'm finding
more interference confusion um
the other thing is in learning related
languages i like i believe that the
biggest issue in language learning is
words
words and phrases period
and i'm i'm very much i emphasize you
know comprehension if you can understand
the language you'll eventually get to
speak it
if you can't understand the language you
can't talk to anyone if you don't
understand what they're saying to you
the biggest obstacle to comprehension to
me is words if you take spanish and
portuguese the vocabulary is like 85 90
the same yeah identifiably the same
clearly identifiably the same so if from
a passive comprehension point of view it
doesn't take very long
for uh you as a spanish speaker to learn
portuguese or vice versa now to activate
that of course you gotta you gotta speak
a lot but you're already in a position
where you certainly you can read and if
you do a lot of reading and listening
you can get to where you understand so
so to me vocabulary is big so in the
slow in the slavic languages
the similarity call it the lexical
distance you know the similarity in
vocabulary is not as great as is the
case with the romance languages so
uh you know ukrainian may only share 60
of its vocabulary with russian
uh you know and and then check and stuff
like that so so the the the vocabulary
is a bigger problem but the
fundamental principles of the grammar
are this are very similar but the actual
endings which is a big bug bear in
slavic languages can differ quite a bit
but and then they're minor differences a
bit like portuguese and spanish yeah i
guess what we're describing here is kind
of the basis for in a way it's a basis
for you want to call it public lottery
it's that isn't it and i i've done
spoken to to richard uh simcott many
times about exactly this about the how
he likes to work with
uh
he would you know he likes to work with
families of languages and he will
explain that that process of kind of
losing one to kind of springboard onto
the next
and it and it absolutely does get easier
and i think like one of the
start to go over the tangent but i think
this this like this this concept of
familiarity with the the process of
acquiring a language is is one thing
that i i see this is a huge
a huge advantage for someone who's been
through that process
just the same way it's a huge
disadvantage for someone who hasn't been
through the language process before
right
um
because you know if you haven't been
through this process of learning a
language you don't know how to
sorry if you don't
know what the steps are like what the
feeling of progressing is like
you you end up um
generating all these feelings i see this
in people all the time creating all
these kind of self-imposed feelings of
panic or uncertainty about whether
they're doing the right thing or not
and
just a second
hello
richard
hello
okay he's gone
all right let me just pull this off here
okay
sorry
go ahead that's all fears yeah
um
i've lost my train of thought yeah
you're saying that people have done who
have been through the process and know
how to learn
and i would agree that they're con not
only do they know how to learn they're
confident that they will learn
that if if they follow the process that
they're used to they will learn i think
a lot of beginner language learners
aren't really confident that they're
going to learn they've never done it
before they have never experienced
you know mastering another language
just a second
all right done
okay
you know nowadays you can't even lift
the phone off the the rocker there
because the phones they've kind of lived
separately from there
yeah you know anyway
um and but i think this this this works
well you know once you have been through
that process it compounds
for
for you know those who have learned a
lot of language and so coming back to
this thing of learning your fourth or
fifth romance or slavic language
you not only have that that ability to
kind of springboard off what you already
know right but that combined with the
fact that you have a knowledge and
experience of the language learning
process it does make it significantly
easier to acquire a new language
absolutely
but and i think to some extent and this
is something we'll discuss at the
montreal north american are you you're
going to be there i am indeed excellent
super the montreal north american
polyglot symposium i think it's called
which is kind of scary you know actually
i think most of us i i'm looking forward
to meeting all these people because i
haven't met them but it's mostly about
having fun learning languages so the
word north american polyglot symposium
may scare people off really it's about
having fun learning languages and and
convincing people that it's really not
that difficult and and that people can
have different approaches
uh and like in my case for example i'm
not too hung up about what i'm able to
say two or three months into the process
i'm more concerned about what i'm going
to be able to say six months or a year
uh you know into the process
because to me language learning is not a
matter of weeks even going from
portuguese to spanish or spanish to
portuguese i've never found it to be a
matter of weeks now there are people on
the internet who learn icelandic in two
weeks but i'm not one of those to me
it's it it takes a long time and so my
concern is what am i going to be able to
do with the language
watch movies read books listen to stuff
have intelligent conversations with
people where am i going to be at after
six months
or a year so well this is something that
i'd like to ask you about because i mean
i um
as i mentioned earlier my language
learning process has always been driven
by by
need or desire or community in some way
it's always been very uh very
instinctive
um
so
as i mean you speak many more languages
than me and so i would be interested to
know from from your perspective what is
the balance for you for these languages
that
yeah let's see who that is
just a second i'll take it
hello
sir i'm in the middle of a skype
conversation i can't talk now
can i talk later
okay
thanks bye
okay
so i'd be interested to know from from
your side like what the languages that
you've learned from what's the
proportion for you for languages that
really factor into your daily life and
are things that you've learned very much
for a purpose and those which are more
of a you know an intellectual pursuit or
out of interest and do those mix i mean
do you find that languages that you just
dabble in for example later on become a
key part of your your life how does that
dynamic work
well i mean
the first languages that i learned uh
you know french for example i got very
interested at university and then
subsequently went to france and studied
there for three years so it was very
much a part of my daily life
uh chinese i was working for the
canadian government and i was sent to
hong kong to learn mandarin chinese it
was a full-time job and i followed up
that by going to china regularly with
canadian business people and so forth
late 60s early 70s
then i lived in japan for nine years so
those three languages which are also my
strongest languages those are languages
that i um
needed you know i had a practical need
for
but in all of those languages
especially i discovered with the chinese
my major activity was listening and
reading like i believe that no matter
what else you do to learn a language
speak attend class i find that i can't
escape from the necessity to do a lot of
listening and reading in the language
and when i lived in japan i never went
to school
to language school but i just spent a
lot of time listening in the car reading
listening reading
now when i get to the all the other
languages
i mean i i did business in sweden i use
my swedish i did some business in
germany
but overwhelmingly it's been more and
certainly with the more recent languages
like the slavic languages in korean and
so forth
it's more out of interest like i'm
reading books right now on ukrainian
history i'm listening to audiobooks in
polish
i'm learning about and my motivation
there is
i just want to understand poland as a
country as a culture ukraine russia
korea
uh
of course when i meet like i took the
trouble of flying to toronto to spend a
day with a bunch of ukrainian speakers
at the ukrainian ukraine business forum
you know uh so i like to speak to people
but it's not practical with 15 languages
i can't surround myself with speakers of
15 languages i also have a social life i
have my wife and my you know my kids and
grandchildren sometimes you just want to
kick back and watch a bit of tv as well
well i don't actually watch a lot of tv
except for hockey but uh
yeah so so you know i think it's a
factor of age too like
so
certainly when i was living in japan i
was speaking japanese every day doing
business and so forth and so on but
right now i would say that the bulk of
it is more of a enjoying accessing the
language the culture of the history the
country expanding my horizons
and of course every opportunity if i if
i if i were to hear ukrainian on the
street god i'd be all over those people
they wouldn't they would be you know
victims
they would know exist and then korean is
the same way and russian or whatever so
obviously you like to use the language
but the emphasis
most recently because it's more
practical like 70 of my study time is
listening so i listen while cleaning the
table and doing the dishes i listen in
the car i listen while working out i
listen listen listen listen then and
then i go and work on link as you know
and i save words and phrases and i kind
of mine that text for for words and
phrases then i go back and i listen so
that's the bulk of of of my experience i
simply can't go out every evening here
with ukrainians and koreans and and
russians and so sure you know i um
i went to the uh a gathering in berlin
last month and um
it's the third time that i've been and i
decided that i wanted to learn a bit of
german because it's always been on my
radar but i've never actually taken the
step to do it because i've never had
that
i've never had that strong enough reason
to to really start but i decided to
spend a month learning german so i kind
of went i just bought a a textbook and i
worked through it's all i did
um you know very straightforward right
and i i was i've got to say it was the
most enjoyable
learning experience i've had since i can
remember for the simple reason that i
was able to read
right without any uh particular trouble
and i was as opposed to japanese for
example you mean right which is what i'm
getting onto because i was absolutely
bowled over by not only how how
oh
we're losing it here and time yeah sorry
i missed you there we go we had a brief
hiccup in our skype connection so you're
bowled over by
by the fact that the the fact that you
can listen and read at the same time
just how much that affects the learning
process i've known this for some time
but i've found in the last three
languages that i've learned it's been
very difficult to do that which are
these which are these these so these
would be japanese cantonese and arabic
okay
egyptian arabics or dialects of arabic
right now um
japanese to a lesser extent because you
you know obviously with the iran and the
katakana you have a certain access early
on right cantonese is not a written
language for the most part um
arabic dialects are
similarly to cantonese you just
generally don't write them down right
um and so i think if i'd stayed in japan
longer and i'd really focused on reading
kanji then i probably would have
progressed a little bit further but in
the case of cantonese arab particular in
particular um i know some chinese
characters i don't know anywhere near
enough right um there is virtually there
is no standardized writing system in
arabic dialects it's all over the place
even the locals don't know how to write
so i've basically the last two languages
aside from quite apart quite aside from
being extremely difficult languages i
have not been able to read for the most
part and i've found this to be
absolutely crippling
um
when compared to um my
previous experiences right only if
you've got a
large distance between languages i'm
familiar with but you've got that
handicap of not being able to read
so um so i wanted to ask you about
your experience with asian languages and
to
well maybe just your general reflections
on what i've just said um well yeah i
mean first of all the easier it is to
read the better so
uh for example when i read polish on
link you know i i've got this i'm
reading
it's again i was able to find a an
audiobook for which i have the e-book so
i import the e-book into link and i go
through it and i'm saving words and
phrases and i can listen to it
and it's in the latin alphabet so
however much i have read in russian and
i have read tons in russian i have read
books i have read newspaper articles and
i read it without a problem it's that
much easier if it's in your own alphabet
and that's just talking about an
alphabet you know because the russian
alphabet the cereal like alphabet is an
alphabet it's consistent it's an
alphabet so
chinese but you know i read i've read so
much in chinese i'm quite comfortable
reading in chinese i read chinese better
than i read japanese
and so but reading to me language
learning is as i said before is words
and the best way to increase your
vocabulary is reading
and the listening is where you take your
words and develop patterns in your head
so that you can eventually use them
because you gotta you gotta hear them
and you gotta hear them again and again
and again and then you you start to be
able to use them so to me it's all about
wrestling listening and reading and i
don't like listening to stuff that i
can't read
until i am well enough along in the
language that that i don't need it i'm
that way in russian i can listen to you
know news commentary discussions
whatever audiobooks in russian i
understand essentially 80 90 percent of
it but until you're past 50 i want to
read it
so if you like for me so getting back to
asian languages my first asian language
was chinese
and i learned whatever it was three four
thousand characters and and my major
activity in
in chinese was listening and reading
and and i i learned it very quickly
because
unlike a lot of the other people who
were studying i spent a lot of time
in those days long before this was the
day of the open reel tape recorder and
stuff so you there was no online
dictionary so there was no link so i had
to buy every possible book i could find
that was a chinese reader with a
glossary
and i just went through every book that
i could find and chinese literature
chinese history chinese this chinese
that with glossary and there were lots
of them and so big focus on reading
come to japan i learned the hiragana
katakana that's not a big deal
i have a big advantage over other people
going at japanese because i can read the
characters even though they're
pronounced differently
in japanese i don't have to actually go
through and learn them all now i've
already learned them so yeah the answer
is
a lot of people like if you're living in
egypt and you're talking to people every
day you're going to pick up egyptian
arabic but if you're studying in london
or in vancouver
i i you know i just think would be very
difficult like my method of learning is
and that's why we've created link is
like focus on listening and reading
build up the vocabulary and and reading
is is just so powerful because i i often
think of it this way it's in the olden
days they had no writing like 5 000
years ago
so they had oral
and then we got the first way of
recording things was writing and now we
have
you know mp3 players but it's all
different ways of recording the language
so that you can then access the language
and start creating the neural networks
that you need so yeah to me if you can't
read the language
much much more difficult to learn
absolutely
i i think i mean so
given it seems i think the the path that
you've taken through those asian
languages is is probably a very good one
and i don't i don't know if that was
intentional or not but it seems i mean
starting with chinese if you you're able
to get that hard work done out oh yeah
at the beginning you cracked the the the
nut haven't you um
yeah i mean my
as a result of these difficulties what
i've ended up doing with these languages
is over compensating on the speaking
side because of the because of the fact
that um the reading's been so
challenging um i
learn pretty much exclusively through
conversations right
and
um
my own in the case of
i kind of invent these kind of pseudo
ways of
recording words on paper right
in order to speed up because the problem
is
the other thing about obviously reading
writing is if you can't write quickly
you slow down the whole process so much
so that it becomes a huge drain on your
on your energy right so in the case of
arabic at the beginning of writing stuff
in a kind of weird translation but it
serves the purpose of recording
something so you can then go off and
memorize it but i very much kind of
overcompensate for the speaking and um
so in the case of japanese i speak
japanese fairly often in london but i do
it through arranging to go out for
dinner with friends
holy evening speak and there's no
there's no bigger pleasure than that i
mean that's i'm you know i'm in heaven
when i'm doing that it's fantastic
but you know i'm very aware that it's
i would not call it an efficient
learning method at all i mean i was able
to get to that stage
thanks to living in japan right but
reverse engineering that
i wouldn't feel confident doing it part
of the problem too is that uh i mean i
enjoy reading books in the language
learning about the history blah blah and
you need a lot of vocabulary for that
that's the problem with with just
speaking it's it's it ends up being a
much more limited vocabulary
that's all and it's more difficult to
organize like i can get in
two hours just in terms of being in the
car and stuff like that i'm listening
i'm reading
to try to organize to go out to dinner
with a group of ukrainians is just much
more difficult much more difficult to
organize but just one thing i was going
to say you know uh
i agree with you that chinese then to
japanese i wish the koreans used their
hanja you know their characters it would
make it easier but i think that that it
is in fact becoming easier for people to
learn multiple languages and i was just
musing today and i don't want to touch
on a sensitive point here but with
britain out of the european union
uh i think it's inevitable that german
will become a more important language
within the european union i mean already
countries in eastern europe that trade
so heavily with germany they're learning
german more and more
uh undoubtedly english will be less
important i mean it's still the
scandinavians and and the the well i
mean they can also learn german i just
think german will become more important
um
i mean if if russia ever
becomes a little bit less column
aggressive in their approach to world
affairs potentially they could be
in terms of the influence of their
language
the russian language could be quite
influential in europe uh spanish could
obviously in latin america it's not so
difficult for the brazilians to learn
spanish maybe spanish could spanish
italian the romance languages we could
end up in a situation where
instead of everyone having to learn
english where it would be considered
normal that people speak three or four
languages including for example in asia
chinese people have a a real advantage
in learning the japanese or korean
japanese people have the characters they
can learn chinese in other words that an
educated person whether he be or she be
asian latin american european whatever
that it's normal to be a quote polyglot
in fact becomes the norm not in terms of
15 languages but in terms of three or
four and so that when you meet with
people somebody said what language shall
we use well we can speak a bit of uh
spanish and we can speed up seek a bit
of japanese or whatever but that's
probably wrong
it's a fantastic aspiration i mean i i
run a monthly monthly meetup here in
london called polyglot pub
can't get away from this word polylife i
would like to
but um you know in those events you know
we have mostly english people coming
down all of whom are polyglots all who
speak a bunch of language we sit there
and we speak
uh
in fairness we speak mostly in english
it's one of those kind of meta things i
think but we're all capable of speaking
different languages my observation on
that is that you know living in london
which is one of the most multicultural
places on earth right
you you stop your average english person
on the street
and you say you ask them to speak in a
different language
it's going to be a very short
conversation
you know now i i obviously this to a
certain extent is because we don't have
that much need for other languages
english being the lingua franca
um but it is interesting
i guess i imagine you feel like the same
thing as well in the us
um
although perhaps you know spanish being
the predominant second language there i
mean there may be a little bit more
there but it is it always strikes me how
much of an upward and uphill battle it
is to try to get native english speakers
to learn other languages
and i wonder with
even with this amount of uh
multiculturalism around us
i i wonder you know what it would
actually take
for that to happen but it's obviously
like a fantastic aspiration well i think
first of all um the situation in canada
is very similar in vancouver unless the
person is an asian origin person even
there are no guarantee just because they
location there's no guarantee they're
going to speak chinese or any asian
language
yeah english on the north american
continent is is
just the most useful language
period
but i was looking more at other parts of
the world so in europe every dutchman
swede spaniard and italian and pole has
to learn english it may be that
they'll be looking at other options like
german if german if germany and germany
austria is the dominant economic force
uh
i i just think you could start seeing
more sort of regional use of other
languages
and it may be that uh even brits
although i don't see it i think if
anything that
britain will be more isolated so maybe
there'll be fewer brits although
personally i think a lot once this stuff
blows over brits will be traveling to
the continent and the people from the
continent will be traveling to europe so
i don't think there'll be much a
difference there but i do think that the
importance of other languages i may be
wrong uh on you know within the european
union it could it could increase that's
all
absolutely yeah that makes perfect sense
i guess that the question then to what
extent is the eu part of the global
you know is it
how
to what extent can we take that that
view of the eu and to what extent is the
eu linked to the more global picture
where english is
i don't know it certainly is doesn't so
many signs of slowing or something no
but if if germany is the dominant
business language in europe and i'm a
japanese manufacturer wanting to ship to
europe or to germany
and
if i am convinced that i can learn
german that's part of the problem you
know then maybe i'd learn german if it's
going to benefit me in my business and
maybe we need to teach languages in a
way that
that gets people interested in different
languages better than we do now you know
i was i was um i saw a video
you published the other day about the
opportunities that um
you've had
work-wise
in language and i thought that was very
very insightful because
um often one of the the question that
comes in is well what's the most useful
language to learn you know or or how can
i you know i i've learned
german how can i get a job with that
right but actually you know your
analysis of that was was a very kind of
organic one and you're saying well you
know put yourself in the in positions
where opportunities can arise
language is not being the main driving
force there
but as a result of those kind of
initiatives you know you can find
yourself um with lots of different
opportunities i've seen that to a
certain extent as well when i worked for
the british council and i think it's
very very interesting and i definitely
recommend people to go in and watch that
you know ali i think you know we don't
want to run out of things to talk about
when we meet in montreal so i have the
feeling we could go on for another
couple of hours but maybe we should cut
it off here
and so i want to thank you very much for
this uh this interesting interview and i
hope this is of interest to the people
who follow us on on youtube
i'm sure it will be it's uh it's a
pleasure to talk to you after so long
and i hope it's the uh the first of many
conversations absolutely bye for now
take it easy
you